hi this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today I'm learning more about article 3
of the Constitution Article three
assists the judicial branch of
government including the Supreme Court
his job is to interpret the laws of the
United States to learn more about
article 3 in the judicial branch I asked
two experts to give me some more
information Jeff Rosen is the president
and CEO of the National Constitution
Center and he's written extensively
about the courts and the Supreme Court
in particular
Richard Garnett is a professor of law
and political science at the University
of Notre Dame School of Law Jeff can you
tell us a little bit about the framers
vision for the judicial branch how much
power did they intend for the judicial
branch to have well let's start by
reading the text that's always the best
place to start and the text of article
three the very first sentence says the
judicial power of the United States
shall be vested in one Supreme Court and
in such inferior courts as Congress may
from time to time establish the framers
expected that we would have a Supreme
Court and that would be separate from
the legislature and the president but it
was up for Congress to decide what other
federal courts we'd have if any and it's
so interesting that the framers are so
focused on a system where state courts
are the main interaction that people
have with the judicial system they
didn't even require Congress to set up
inferior federal courts at all so what
does article 3 tell us about how the
judicial branch is supposed to be
structured well it doesn't say a whole
lot it's interesting so some people are
surprised when you actually read the
text of article 3 it sets up the Supreme
Court and it says that all of the
federal judicial power is gonna be in
that Supreme Court but it doesn't tell
us anything about say courts of appeals
or trial courts it clearly envisions
that Congress is going to create some
but it really did leave it to Congress
to decide how to structure the judicial
system so where are some of the ways
that the role of the Supreme Court has
changed over time well I think it's fair
to say that you know there's a
there's a lot more federal law than
there used to be and so there are more
questions that are potentially questions
for the Supreme Court then there used to
be I mean if you think of the country's
early history most of the legal action
was in the States and the state courts
and the state legislatures there wasn't
that much there weren't that many
questions for the Supreme Court to
answer as the federal government grows
as federal law expands that creates more
work for the Supreme Court
what does equal protection mean what
does due process mean what's the balance
between the freedom of speech on the one
hand and intellectual property on the
other say these are these are questions
that the founders might not have been
able to envision being judicial
questions Alexander Hamilton in
Federalist 78 famously said that the
judiciary would be the least dangerous
branch because it had neither person or
sword the framers thought that Congress
would be the most dangerous branch
because it had the most enumerated
powers the Presidency's second limited
but constrained powers and the judiciary
the least dangerous because it didn't
have the army and it had no money and
all it could do was issue judgments and
hope that they would be accepted by the
other branches so say that I'm a Supreme
Court justice good work me and a case
comes before me and it's up to me now to
interpret the Constitution in such a way
that I can answer questions about this
certain case so what would be some of
the tools that I could use to help me in
my interpretation well there's obviously
deep and fascinating disagreements among
people about how exactly Court should do
that but one place where you could start
and I think there'd be common ground
here is that all all justices believe
that it's important to ask well how has
the Supreme Court answered questions
like this in the past so the first place
you would look would be to the courts
own precedence right how has the court
answered questions like this before and
if so what did the court say because
there is a strong sense that you know
the root the rule of law needs
predictability and consistency and so
courts really do make an effort to
their rulings be consistent over time
you might also be interested in
empirical facts what would be the effect
of a particular decision on the country
you might also be interested in theories
of natural law which we talked about in
discussing the 9th amendment are there
even if the right being asserted it
isn't written down in the Constitution
is there some case that it is rooted in
the history and tradition of our law and
that it might come from sources like God
or nature and not government generally
judges have been reluctant to enforce
rights natural rights that don't have a
positive foundation a positive right is
a right that's written down or codified
in some explicit way a natural right
comes from God or nature but in practice
most of the natural rights attended to
be codified in the history or tradition
and state constitutions or state laws so
those would be other places you'd look
to but what's really important for
viewers to remember and I want all of
you guys to try to do this yourselves
try this yourselves at home
separate your constitutional conclusions
from your political conclusions when
you're evaluating a law don't ask do I
think that this form of say gun control
regulation is a good or bad idea as a
policy matter ask yourself do I think
the Second Amendment allows or prohibits
it and entertain the possibility that
your constitutional conclusions might
diverge from your political conclusions
you might think gun control is a good
idea but the Second Amendment prohibits
it where it's a bad idea but the
Constitution allows it and that basic
separation of political from
constitutional conclusions is central to
Hamilton's very theory of judicial
review because that's what stops judges
from being policymakers in robes and
ensures that they're preferring the will
of the people expressed in the
Constitution to those of the legislators
which represent fallible policy views as
we learn from early cases like Marbury
vs. Madison and then even later cases
like Brown versus Board of Education the
Supreme Court can render decisions that
then no one enforces so how did how has
the Supreme Court avoided becoming kind
of a moot point yeah there's a there's a
story and it might be apocryphal but
it's a good story anyway
that President Andrew Jackson said after
the Supreme Court issued an opinion that
he didn't like he said well the Supreme
Court has issued its opinion now let
them enforce it and basically making the
point that all they could do was issue
an opinion and it was up to others to
decide to comply I think you know
American culture and this is something
for us to be grateful for it's been
built up over a long time has generally
been that we have a strong norm that
elected officials should follow the law
as it's been declared by the federal
courts now there have been as you know
controversies about Court decisions
throughout our history whether it was
the the Dred Scott case which President
Lincoln hated or as you said Brown
versus Board which was resisted by some
southern officials after it came down
the the courts ability to get its
judgments enforced depends on its
credibility and on America's culture of
respecting the rule of law if the courts
credibility goes away or if Americans
stop respecting the rule of law then the
courts judgments will will have less
force so the Supreme Court exercises the
power of judicial review which means
that it reviews the actions of the
executive branch and the legislative
branch and can declare those actions
unconstitutional do you think the
framers intended for the court to use
that power to check the other branches
of government most scholars would agree
that it was widely believed that the
Supreme Court would have the power to
review the acts of both other federal
officials and of state governments and
to decide whether or not those acts were
consistent with the Constitution now
there was there was a lot of
disagreement about you know how how
excited people were about that power and
again some people worried that the
Supreme Court might abuse its power of
judicial review but the basic idea that
it's one of the jobs of a court to make
sure that the acts of other officials
are constitutional are consistent with
the written constitution that idea
pre-existed Marbury that idea was
clearly I in the minds of the founders
when they created the Supreme Court
I'm happy to say yes the framers did
intend for the courts to have the power
of judicial review and I'm confident of
that both because the power was
exercised by courts before and after the
framing and also because Alexander
Hamilton in Federalist 78 so explicitly
puts the case for judicial review it's
such a shame that in that great musical
we've got the room where it happened but
we don't have you know the judicial
review where it happened because it
would be a great song about why Hamilton
thought that judicial review followed
logically from the very theory of
popular sovereignty it really isn't the
job of unelected judges to try to update
and improve the Constitution that the
people ratified in some cases this isn't
much of a challenge but in others say in
cases having to do with the freedom of
speech or in cases having to do with the
War Powers and so on it can be a
challenge it can be a challenge to
figure out what exactly the provision
meant to those who ratified it and it
can be a challenge to decide whether if
at all the original meaning needs to be
updated in light of more current events
now there there's of course much to say
in response to Hamilton and we could
have a whole Constitution law of course
on the responses to Hamilton his very
theory of judicial review is premise
Donn the idea that the Constitution
represents the will of the people more
emblematical II or profoundly or
fundamentally than those of ordinary
laws and the obvious first response is
hey how can you say that the will of a
bunch of dead white guys from 1787
really represents the will of We the
People today more accurately than a law
that Congress passes and the answer to
the objection is well it's because the
Constitution was passed by a special
procedure was unusually deliberative it
took a long time to propose and it
didn't gain the status of supreme law
until it was ratified by special
conventions that were specially called
for the purpose and it was that long
process of deliberation that gives that
constitutional text the right to speak
in we the people's name how
the legislative or executive branch
check the power of the Supreme Court
yeah that's a our Constitution has a
number of these interesting checks and
balances features right so the the three
branches are distinct but there's
various ways in which they get into each
other's business right the president can
veto a law the President appoints
justices but of course the Senate has to
say about whether to confirm them and so
on
so the branches are separate but they
are related and they check each other
well we remember from the text of
article three that the Constitution
authorizes Congress to set up such
inferior courts as it may from time to
time choose to ordain and establish
Congress didn't have to create inferior
courts it can create them it can change
them there's a debate right now about
whether the ninth US Circuit Court of
Appeals which occupies as much of the
West should be split up and Congress can
split it up if it wants Congress can
change the number of Supreme Court
justices there were originally six
justices and the number went up and down
before settling around nine in the
rather settling at nine in the 1860s so
Congress could choose change the number
of justices to punish a president on
political grounds when Thomas Jefferson
was coming in after the election of 1800
the outgoing Federalist Congress was so
determined to punish him that they
changed the size of the Supreme Court to
deny him the right to make any
appointments the other branches can
check the court in a number of ways so
the most dramatic would be you know you
could impeach a justice for high crimes
and misdemeanors that doesn't happen
very often another way which doesn't
happen all that often but but could is
Congress can check the court by for
example not funding it or by limiting
the issues that the court is allowed to
hear Congress can control the what's
what's called the jurisdiction of the
court the court only gets to answer the
questions that Congress gives it the
power to answer now again Congress is
reluctant to do that but it has
sometimes in the past
than it it could if if Congress thought
it were necessary Congress can engage in
jurisdiction stripping there's only a
small category of cases that the Supreme
Court is required to hear but broadly
the court has a broad discretion over
its docket and if Congress wanted to say
hey Supreme Court you're not allowed to
hear any cases involving abortion for
example it arguably could do that
although such a law might be
constitutionally challenged I remember
being in law school just kind of
indignant at the idea that Congress
could violate the separation of powers
so flagrantly my great law professor
Akhil amar convinced me that this has
been done throughout American history
that before during the Civil War
Congress deprived the court of the right
to hear certain cases involving national
security and so forth so Congress can if
it chooses exempt certain categories of
cases those that are not in the original
jurisdiction of the court from being
heard there's also the question of
whether Congress could impose term
limits for Supreme Court justices and
there's a proposal floating about to
have 18 year terms for the justices and
give each president the right to appoint
two justices and have justices retire
after 18 year terms there's a vigorous
debate about whether that could be done
by an ordinary statute or whether it
would require a constitutional amendment
well if you had to say there was one big
takeaway about article three that
students should remember what might it
be that when courts strike down laws as
unconstitutional
they're not wording the will of the
people they're supposed to be supporting
it because the Constitution represents
the will of the people ordinary laws
represent the will of our
representatives and the Constitution is
supreme law so that's why it Trump's
ordinary legislation you know Americans
of good faith and good reason have been
disagreeing about the courts role for a
long time I think a challenge for the
court is finding the right balance
between asserting its independence and
exercising judicial review on the one
hand but on the other being mindful of
the fact that it is undemocratic that
judicial review
sometimes involves setting aside what
the people have decided they want and
that's an awesome power and it shouldn't
be overused so the court from time to
time in history has been criticized for
perhaps going beyond what the
Constitution actually requires and
instead enforcing perhaps their own
policy preferences or their own
political morality so we've learned that
article 3 is crucial to the system of
checks and balances that limits the
power of government in the United States
the Supreme Court exercises judicial
review to ensure that the executive
branch and legislative branch act within
the confines of the Constitution but the
other branches have plenty of checks on
the judicial branch as well one of the
most central questions about the Supreme
Court is the relevance of the
Constitution to the issues we face today
as Richard garnet points out some
scholars might say it's undemocratic to
overrule the will of the people as
expressed through their elected
representatives based on the
Constitution but as Jeff Rossen argues
the Constitution is the supreme law of
the land and therefore striking down a
law as unconstitutional isn't forwarding
the will of the people but rather
preserving it to learn more about
article 3 visit the National
Constitution Center's interactive
Constitution and Khan Academy's
resources on US government and politics